let's start with love
your parents had a Complicated Love
Story
divorced twice married three times
what did you learn about love from your
mom and dad and their love story
that it's messy
that it takes work
that
it's ugly
no matter how great a mess it is
don't go to bed
until you've
come back together to either Embrace or
admit that you truly love each other
even if you hadn't solved what the hell
you're bitching about
that
love will win
in the end literally three to two
with my mom and dad yeah
um
and that even in the two divorces and in
the two times where they couldn't live
with each other
they still loved each other they just
couldn't
live with each other at that time for
whatever reason they needed and I don't
know the details if they needed their
space Freedom or what but they were
never out of love
with each other
um
and that
as a parent
if you just if you when we're not sure
what to do
and you people give you a thousand books
and advice
as a parent
if your kid
knows you love them
you're in the black
that's the main thing it won't work
without that
um and it can work and we'll usually can
work with that
they just know that fact
so it's not just love for each other
it's the love for the bigger family
that ultimately helps you persist
through the ups and downs
well
[Applause]
I mean I don't know how much
particularly my mom and dad were
foreign together at times maybe when
they didn't want to because they had
children I don't actually think they
considered that
I I I I think they were
much less conscientious than say
I am
today I think my mom and dad were more
like
they'll be fine we love them they'll be
fine but we'll we'll cross that bridge
when we get there right now they would
let's work it out between you and I is
what I think my mom and dad were saying
to each other or or not they uh um
they they
wanted and needed a relationship that
was a tidal wave Rocky
right angles two namis and to this day
in in my life with Camille and I which I
don't I like a river has some swerves
and some some streams and some Rapids
but I'm not looking for a tidal wave my
mom's like
what's all this everything's so smooth
yeah come on come on come on come on so
she challenges
like Vitality because that's what my mom
needed to communicate I don't think my
dad needed it as much
uh that uh the the the the the the the
the the the the hard angles uh um that
their relationship between I don't think
my dad needed as much as my mom
but the clashes demonstrated the passion
that underlies the love yes and that's
I've I've always been asked you know
when I talk about my parents love
relationship I tell the stories
that are actually sometimes quite
violent
and there's some good stories there
they're beautiful I think they're
beautiful yeah I think they're beautiful
too but I've had people go wait a minute
that was unhealthy you can't dead and I
was like no that's again back to the
beginning Love's messy in that what I
love about those stories is
that's where the love was actually it
was tested
and it could have broke and been over
yeah and it never was again the love won
in the kitchen floor or the blood's
drawn
knifes are pulled ketchup ketchups all
over
but we make love on the kitchen floor to
end yeah I mean come on beautiful so as
romantic as it gets right there whoa